so i'm guessing that you clicked on this
video because you are also trying to
introduce some balance into your life
and one of the most important things to
doing that is sleep which is where i
want to talk about the helix sleep
mattress i've had my helix mattress for
over a year now and it continues to give
me a really really great night's sleep
in fact i have two at my house and one
of them is used in the guest room and
anytime we get a guest and they sleep on
it they say that it's one of the best
sleeps they've ever had helix sleep
makes premium mattresses and bedding
that are customized to fit your needs
and conveniently ships right to your
door and helix knows that everybody
sleeps very differently so they made a
sleep quiz that matches your unique body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you i'm personally
a back sleeper that likes a medium
mattress and i share the mattress with
my husband and dogs and so i have the
dusk luxe mattress and i've had this
mattress for over a year and i really
truly love it it actually gives me a
really great night's sleep every day and
i don't wake up hurting or sore or
anything like that so the best part
about all this is that after you take
the sleep quiz helix ships their
mattresses straight to your door with
free shipping in the u.s and if it makes
you nervous that you're buying a
mattress that you've never tried before
helix has a 100 night sleep trial and so
after three months if you don't like it
you'll get a free refund and they'll
pick it up for you the mattress comes
roll up in a box and it's pretty easy to
set up yourself plus helix mattresses
have a 10 year warranty and they even
offer financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is never far away i really truly
genuinely love my helix and i think you
will too and so if you're interested and
you're looking for a new bed then check
out the helix mattress you can click the
link below or go to helixleep.com hello
myuco and get up to 200 off your helix
mattress plus two free pillows
i just woke up from the fattest nap ever
so move fast and break things i'm
assuming that a lot of y'all have heard
this slogan before because it's one of
the most popular sayings in tech that
i've ever heard of it's very common it
really kind of just talks about you
should always be moving fast and
breaking things there should be a bias
towards action you should be doing
things and moving as quickly as possible
for the sake of innovation and creating
cool stuff and yeah this whole like bias
towards action and doing stuff is
definitely helpful in things like a
career and if you're working in a
corporate environment and you're trying
to like develop the newest products and
stuff like that but i'm realizing that
there are just times in life where you
just need to slow down
and like just wait
this is a very very very hard thing for
me because
i'm generally kind of an impatient
person you can ask anyone in my life and
they'll say that i'm very impatient
about things like i like seeing results
quickly i like seeing things happen and
progress in my eyes and i like being
able to see that progress
and also just being able to like just
get feedback on things that i'm doing
quickly and i know a lot of that comes
from just like my working style but
that's also just kind of who i am as
like a person in life and stuff so the
whole like slowing down
and like just
seeing how things go
not really my thing but recently i like
really needed to slow down because like
ever since mid-april-ish i'm not gonna
lie to you i felt very blah about like
making videos and just like other
things in life in general like my
motivation is kind of at an all-time low
and i'm not freaking out about it but it
is kind of weird to me because this is
so unlike me and so the first thing that
i did you know learning from my past
lessons where i felt very blah and not
fully there and kind of out of it is
just i started taking a lot of breaks so
i allowed myself to procrastinate on
things to create space and time for
things like rest and relaxation my
parents were here and so i spent a lot
of time with them i also said no to some
opportunities because i was just like i
think i just need to like sit tight
maybe or like take a break and just like
chill for a bit and uh ideally this will
all be over in like a few weeks but it
wasn't it's mid-may now and i still feel
very blah and uh i've taken i feel like
a lot of breaks and i still feel like
i'm not quite where i want to be and so
yeah this is me in the present moment
learning probably one of the hardest
lessons of all
to slow down and it has been
quite painful yeah it's been uh it's
been really really hard in slowing down
you know i've done all of this
introspection about just like okay
in slowing down it implies that i wanted
to move fast which means that like where
am i moving fast towards i'm moving fast
towards
something and at first i didn't even
know what that something was but then
eventually i realized that i'm trying to
move towards a version of myself that i
expect myself to be at where i'm
performing i'm moving fast i'm just like
gliding through time and space and life
effortlessly kind of thing i think
that's the thing that i've been waiting
for
that i don't have yet and i've
definitely shared this from previous
videos before but i do have kind of
really unrealistically high expectations
of myself which it's definitely gotten
better uh like absolutely but
i have
like this thing of like i need to be at
my best at all times and i cannot let up
or else i might die
that's actually probably where a lot of
my anxiety comes from actually and while
i was doing all this introspection stuff
too i watched like previous videos of
mine like the it's okay to take a break
video and literally i watched it and i
was like okay yep i hear you i need to
take a break but then honestly my first
gut reaction after that was just like
yes i've been taking breaks like i'm
ready for what's next please now
come and think about it this whole kind
of like i want it now it's very like
child like which is fine i'm not beating
myself up about it but just noticing
that about myself that i'm like i want
it now not later now
of course i've talked to my therapist
about this a ton of times like i'm
always like ugh like why aren't things
going faster why aren't things going my
way i don't understand
and it's been a very gradual process to
have her say like trust me weaker things
are happening it's going to be fine
but one analogy that she said in
particular really kind of helped unlock
it for me and the analogy itself was
when seeds are planted in a garden most
of the growing for like the first few
weeks happens underneath the surface
where you can't see the roots are
growing down towards the ground like
well before you even see that first
speck of green on the surface
and that's important for plants because
they need to root down first and really
get a good hold of the ground before
they can even reach for the sky
or else they might just like fall over
and die like the roots are how they get
their nutrients and i've been seeing her
for so many years she knows me you know
and she was like trust me where you go
these seeds that you've planted
all along the way are definitely growing
and they're percolating underneath the
surface and you can't see them but trust
that it is happening it's funny because
she told me this analogy right around
the time that i started gardening and i
was just like i planted these seeds and
why aren't things coming out and she was
just like
will they have to root first when you go
but it's actually been a very useful
analogy for me to think about like
what's going on in my life really did
contextualize and help me to be at peace
with what's going on right now
and specifically in that not everything
that's happening is going to be visible
or obvious to you and that progress is
kind of happening in ways that you
wouldn't even expect like in
subconscious mind and so even if it
feels like you're not making progress
like in a visible meaningful way that
feels
measurable it is happening we are always
constantly growing and changing and so
because not everything's gonna be
obvious sometimes you know in the
meantime it's okay to just sit back and
wait for things to happen because let me
tell you i feel like since april i've
done everything everything that i feel
like i could have done to try to like
kick start my engine and it ain't
working and i'm like starting to get to
a point where i'm like why the heck
isn't it working
and i'm really trying to like lean into
the like
it's okay if it doesn't work
you're supposed to just wait and like
see what happens because that's life
and granted this is still like i said
really really hard for me to do i have
to basically practice every day not to
scorn myself for not moving as fast as i
possibly could and also i have to not
beat myself up for not having the
motivation that i know i could have but
that's the thing it's an everyday
practice it's like anything else that
you're gonna practice like sports or
musical instrument or practicing cooking
i'm not going to be great at it at the
beginning but over time from showing up
every day and doing this thing i'm going
to get better at it and through
practicing i'm realizing that really i
can't be going 100 miles per hour every
single day through life and through work
if i don't also know how to go 20 miles
an hour and stop to notice the lessons
like this one along the way
you